>>> This morning the Ukrainian
military says Russia launched
more than 50 cruise missiles in
yet another wave of strikes
targeting critical
infrastructure in Kyiv and
cities across the country.
Ukraine claiming it intercepted
44 of those missiles.
Kyiv's mayor, though, says one
attack hit an energy facility
that powered some 350,000
apartments.
CNN's nic Robertson joining us
live from Kyiv.
As I understand it you are in an
area where one of the lines
there -- you are at a line where
people are trying to get water,
the mayor has also said some 80%
of the city's population doesn't
have water supply right now
because of the attacks.
What more can you tell us about
just how significant that damage
is?
>> Reporter: Yeah, the mayor
says he hopes to get the
supplies up and running, part of
the city the water is coming
back on, but here you have a
line of people, this water
spigot they are lining up for
here is one of dozens around the
city.
So this is how people are going
to be getting their water in the
coming days until the city
officials can get the water
supplies back up and running.
People I have been talking to
here tell me they are okay with
this, obviously they don't like
T but they're okay with it, it's
not going to make them leave the
city.
They're going to stay here.
They expected the situation to
get worse.
Russia has been hitting the
power generating facilities
across this country now for
about three weeks and it's
reduced the capacity of the
power grid to really keep a lot
of the main functions in big
cities like Kyiv up and running.
That meeting today with strikes
today they have been able to
take out so much of the water
capacity in the city.
Also across the city the
cellular network normally a good
4G signal now reduced to a poor
3G signal.
The impacts are beginning to be
felt more widely.
The government saying today ten
different regions were affected
by strikes, 18 different
strikes, a hydropower plant
north of Kyiv was impacted today
as well as the biggest hydro
electric power plant in the
center of Ukraine that was also
hit.
The key part of Russia's efforts
here is to just -- is to stop
the electrical generating
facilities in the country, stop
the grid working.
>> It is something especially
when you see those pictures and
those numbers, people lining up
for that water and their
resolve.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
>>> Joining me to discuss
further Andrea Kendall Taylor.
Good to see you this morning.
When we look at what happened
today, when we look at this
pressure that Russia and
Vladimir Putin are trying to put
on Ukrainians by specifically
targeting infrastructure, not
just electricity, but water,
what does this tell you about
Putin's plan moving forward?
Could he be moving further west
ultimately to target some of
those infrastructure -- some of
the infrastructure there as
well?
>> Well, I think, I mean, as
you're covering the attacks are
horrific and we should not grow
to -- grow immune to them, but
they shouldn't be surprising,
and I think the way that we
understand these attacks is that
as Vladimir Putin is unable to
accomplish his objectives on the
battlefield, he will continue to
terrorize Ukrainian cities, he
will continue to terrorize
Ukrainians to try to get them to
make concessions and end the war
on Russia's terms.
But you covered an interesting
point, Erica, you noted that
Ukraine shot down 44 out of the
50 missiles that Russia launched
and it just underscores how
critical the air defenses are
that the west continues to
provide Ukraine and that will be
key to preventing Putin from
moving west with those attacks.
>> There's not just the
infrastructure that we're
following, right, as those
attacks continue, but also the
fact that Russia is now pulling
out of this grain deal.
Earlier today the Kremlin called
T quote, risky and dangerous.
What do you see as the path
forward here?
Is this just another way that,
you know, that Putin is
essentially trying to hold
Ukraine hostage?
And potentially Europe?
>> Exactly.
I think -- yeah, exactly.
Both of these represent forms of
escalation.
So, again, as he can't
accomplish on the battlefield,
he's looking for any options,
he's leveraging any remaining
influence -- or, I'm sorry, he's
weaponizing any remaining
leverage that he has.
And I think that attacks on the
civilian centers and his
suspension of the grain deal are
related.
As the lights go out and it gets
colder, we're likely to see an
influx of Ukrainian migrants
into Europe.
I also think that Putin is
calculating with an increase in
prices, more food insecurity,
potentially instability in the
south and the Middle East, that
that, too, could push another
wave of migrants up into Europe
to the south.
So those two things could very
well converged and put
tremendous pressure on European
governments.
So I think it's Europe that he
has in his cross hairs and he's
trying to make their support for
Ukraine as costly as possible to
get them to stop their support
because this is a critical
juncture for Putin.
He needs to make it through this
winter without losing additional
territory so he is weaponizing
everything he's got.
>> There's so much talk about
how difficult this winter is
going to be in Ukraine, for
obvious reasons we just
discussed, also in Europe as we
know, we see the prices, we know
what's happening there, we know
what the stressors are at that
point, but the reality is there
has been reporting from the
beginning of the war about how
low morale was among Russian
troops, now all of this added
reporting about how ill prepared
they are.
The impact of this upcoming
winter, I mean, that could also
lead to even further dis consent
among these troops, these
Russian troops.
>> I entirely agree and I think
the key flash point is going to
be the battle over kherson.
We know that Ukraine continues
to make progress there and a lot
of those Russian fighters have
been there for a very long time
and we know that their supply
lines have been significantly
disrupted.
So it's going to make it very
hard for Moscow to get winter
gear into the soldiers there.
So that low morale, I think,
make it increasingly likely that
Ukraine will have success in the
coming weeks or a couple of
months in that area.
But the one thing to note is I
think there's a lot of optimism
in the west about how well
Ukraine is doing, but even with
low morale I think it's still
unlikely that Russian forces
will entirely collapse.